hi guys I'm Eric Vasa and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season
eight episode 12 the key and I would say
this show found the key to a great
episode
negan a brick driving and narrative and
bold interesting ways new stunts
heightened gore in this case full
frontal gore and some world opening
mystery to keep us excited for more
episodes I get Georgie you know the
drill I'm gonna break down this episode
point out all the subtle ways to
connected to past episodes explain what
this all means for Santa whew negan
impressions because unlike the ones
Maggie gave Georgie
this record is broken let's get started
with the big question guys which so a
lot of you guys have between us about
who exactly is Georgie and what is her
community
so the arrival of Georgie is definitely
a game changer to the walking dead her
request for LPS in exchange for a
typewritten document on how to rebuild
society with windmills and aqueducts
suggests that this woman really knows
what she's doing and I gotta say it's
super refreshing for one of these
newcomers to seem reasonable and
practical someone we want to get to know
more like no offense to Jesus and
Ezekiel the larper I love them both in
the comics and in the show but trash
people who speak like lazy Yoda's and
Beach women who kill intruders except
the times they really should just got a
little tiring and I think a lot of that
is due to the actress Jane Atkinson she
played Secretary of State Katherine
Durant on the show house of cards and
she gives off this southern charm of a
wise rational leader whom you just be a
lot better about having in the room so
what do we know about her well if she
typed out that key to a future document
from memory she must be very
knowledgeable about early technology an
engineering or a history professor or
teacher an author or a museum curator
perhaps actually that could be why the
hilltop popped up on her radar
that mansion was formerly known as the
Barrington house a museum that locals
would go visit Georgie is very well
dressed compared to other groups they've
encountered she looks more like she's
ready to host an episode of Sally then
potentially tussle with zombies so that
tells us that her home community must be
very secure and large enough in
population then maybe she would feel the
need to dress this way to gain respect
Georgie also has the
goofy sidekicks Hilda image when Georgie
joked that trust
sounded like a made-up word these days
like flipper sticky
Hilda suggests Kluth and mid suggests
moister Georgie gives her this looked
like what the hell now I've read this as
this could be another female led society
and to a lot of women the word moist
sounds gross
maybe they banned it in fact I have a
lot of questions about the freedom of
speech in this society
notice how Georgie was so particular
about the records being musical only no
spoken word maybe her society has laws
against certain kinds of media musical
and educational only but no George
Carlin comedy albums to rile up the
masses or maybe Georgia just really
hates podcasts either way Georgie's
society must be more advanced than the
others we've seen if she's at the point
of writing books on how to rebuild
civilization and she has enough food to
give to the hilltop as charity they're
probably at least second world some have
suggested that her group might be the
source of that mysterious PPP key card
that Tara found when he just disappeared
in season 7 others have said that they
could be the owners of that helicopter
that Rick saw earlier this season then
again a few episodes back Simon asked
Jadis remember about the helipad and the
landfill so I still think that would
belong to Jadis but maybe that connects
Jadis to Georgie like the landfill could
be a colony or an outcast tribe from
Georgie's community now Georgie did tell
Maggie that she had made this crates for
knowledge trade offer with communities
before but she also said she hasn't
found many communities like theirs and
not one for a very long time which seems
a little unlikely like how do all these
communities located within relatively
close proximity keep not being aware of
each other's existence
my guess is Georgie could be either
lying or she's from somewhere that's
just a bit further away because I don't
imagine she would want to get embroiled
in this drama with negan now there's
another possible explanation for
Georgie's origin but it's a kind of
spoiler from The Walking Dead comics so
a skip to this time if you haven't read
up on the recent issues of the series
okay in the recent run of Robert
it's comics a new community gets
introduced called
the Commonwealth it's a massive
community of 50,000 residents it's
protected by soldiers with stormtrooper
like body armor their leader is a woman
named Pamela who yeah looks and dresses
a little similarly to Georgie but she's
a bit younger the Commonwealth has an
event arena for live concerts which
could explain Georgie's interest in
music but the Commonwealth doesn't show
up until way way later in the comics
beyond the current war with negan even
beyond a bunch of bunch of other stuff
that happens after the negan war after a
time jump so even though the writers had
pulled up the ocean side to the
present-day point in time even though
they come up later in the comics it
would be even crazier for the
Commonwealth to show up here unless
Georgie keeps her word and this really
would be the last we see of her for at
least a few years now Georgie and her
key to the future is just one part of
this episode the real excitement this
episode came from Rick and negan and
there were a lot of interesting ways
this storyline connected the past
episode so let's go over all those in
our segment callbacks
okay first early on when negan checks in
with Dwight Dwight empties this
cigarette pack containing this one last
cig and he and his wife Sherry's wedding
rings this is a callback to season seven
when sherry ran away leaving Dwight the
cigarette pack and the cig with her
lipstick on it as a memento of their old
smoke breaks in the sanctuary sharing
one cigarette was really the only time
they could talk freely after negan took
Shari to be part of his harem ever since
Dwight hid their rings in that pack a
symbol of his secret hatred of negan for
cuckolding him like that now when he and
Simon find Meegan's overturned car and
Simon urges him to join him in turning
against negan Dwight defiantly smokes
this cigarette which I realize isn't the
exact same one as Sherry's this one has
a filter I don't think that one did but
still the symbolism is there he uses
that memento of negan's assholey to
torch negan's car staggering behind
Dwight in the scene is that fully nude
walker Greg Nicotero promised us at the
start of this season he directed this
episode by the way perhaps it's there to
haunt Dwight as another symbol of negan
sexual exploitation of his wife
or maybe Nicotero just said screw it
let's go full frontal
speaking of defiant torches Rick turns
the tables on me in this episode and a
few interesting ways that recall past
moments he finds negan's bat lucille
before negan does dousing it lighter
fluid and setting it ablaze and to do
that he uses this lighter which used to
belong to Glenn come on Rick for letting
me gonzaque for revenge like this also
Rick shows off some serious lumberjack
skills by overhead chucking his axe at
negan this is the same acts that negan
threatened Rick and Carl width on the
day they met back in the season 7
premiere now Rick chops at Meghan's hand
with this axe cause a meganta lose his
hold and fall down in the basement but
unlike the bad guys at home alone two
negan lands on his feet vodka god damn
cat down in the basement Rick struts
around with Lucille taunting vegan by
whistling Adam another example of
redirecting one of Meghan's iconic fear
tactics back at him once again Rick and
negan are now on equal footing when it
comes to their villainy notice how this
episode focuses in on the way negan
covers Lucille and Walker blood and the
way Rick covers Lucille and fire both
men are taking a perfectly lethal weapon
and adding an additional unnecessary
deadly element to it in both cases it's
overkill just designed to scare as I
discussed my breakdown of the lost in
the plunderers both men are now equal
parts sympathetic and sadistic another
callback I liked here in this house of
horrors that they're chasing each other
in Rick finds a boarded-up entry marked
with the warning eaters this feels like
a callback to the pilot of the series
when Rick was in the hospital and found
that door mark don't open dead inside
the fact that Rick now tears down the
barricaded doors shows that he's no
longer a victim running from this
violent world to borrow from another AMC
series Rick is the one who knocks and
while we're talking about this house of
horrors notice how one of the markings
says abandon all hope ye who enter here
that's a famous literary reference to
Dante's Inferno those are the words
written over the gates of hell I'm
guessing this was written by some high
school English teacher with a sense of
humor now if you were watching this
episode closely there were few
other callbacks you might have missed
early on when Rick visits Glenn and
Abraham's graves at the hilltop you may
have noticed a third grave was added
this is Sasha's grave I don't think Rick
has been back to the hilltop since sasha
was buried there
also when Michonne urges Maggie and the
others to give Georgie's message a
chance she references a past time she
asked Rick to trust a newcomer and how
it changed everything now in case you
were wondering she is referring to Aaron
in season five who invited them to join
Alexandria I think this callback is
suggesting that the opportunity Georgie
is offering will be as huge for them now
that Alexandria was to them then there
were also a few little moments that
referenced past episode titles from this
season Simon suggests the missing negan
could be alive or dead somewhere in
between a reference to negan's final
line last episode that gave it its title
alive or dead or some kind of in between
and when debating the Georgie offer
Maggie reasons that there's got to be
something after this could be referenced
in episode 7 this season time for after
when Rick and Jadis discussed the way
alliances would look after the war with
negan but let's talk about the deeper
meaning of this episode now remember its
title is the key a reference to
Georgie's civilization manual a key to a
future in this episode some characters
are aimed toward the future while others
are aiming toward the past when rick has
been at its best
he has been forward thinking in season 6
when making a stand to fend off
Alexandria from Walker's it's because he
imagined a future for his family that
would be a true new beginning the same
goes for when he found his second win at
the end of last season joining forces
with the kingdom in the hilltop he was
all about the future at that point now
Rick is all about the past his brash
actions against neig in this episode
were motivated by vengeance for past
victims Glenn and Sasha and of course
the death of his son Carl meanwhile the
opposite is true for Maggie in the first
part of this season anger over Glen's
death led her to some pretty
unsympathetic decisions like the
inhumane treatment of the Savior
prisoners and killing Dean and at the
start of this episode she reaffirmed
that coldness to Rosita saying she would
feel much better as soon as Nikken was
dead
but that attitude begin to change
recently learning about how Karl's
open-hearted sacrifice brought them a
doctor sadiq started Maggie on this path
toward thinking about the society
they're trying to maintain and now trust
in a new outsider Georgie awarded Maggie
a victory that has eluded Rick since his
dark turn a key to a real future now
let's check in on this week's kill count
just like last week this episode was
actually pretty light on human deaths no
one died this episode but going by
walkers and just general behavior Rick
was the deadliest it looked like he took
down seven walkers he also shot the hell
out of negan's car for no reason
considering he could have just walked
around the side of the car and shot
negan dead right there but you know
blind rage rick has never been the
smartest say miss Rick right right cool
blam blam yes now with the closing
cliffhanger of negan captured by Jadis
here's my question for you guys
is this a good thing for negan or a bad
thing now that he knows Simon disobeyed
him by killing all of Jay desist people
against his orders is to sit down with
Jadis where he can explain that Simon is
just a bad egg trying to stage a mutiny
something that will actually help him
and give him an edge to reclaim
authority over the Savior's it's just
something I've always wondered it as a
war chief negan hasn't really been that
effective
he keeps trusting lieutenants that he
obviously shouldn't trust he's a huge
blind spot all the time it leaves him
outgunned and scrambling for his life in
battle his strategy to cover their
weapons and Walker blood even seems like
a half-measure
Simon's right at that point why not just
kill them all meanwhile negan seems much
more fearsome when you're alone in a
room with them just talking because he's
so damn charming he tricks you into
thinking he's actually reasonable so
after some embarrassing defeats in the
battlefield maybe negan's gleeful
reaction at the end of the episode
because this is really a blessing in
disguise
I don't know comment down below to let
me know your thoughts or tweet me
directly at ei vas and follow new
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos you can like and share this video
and subscribe to new rock stars for all
of our Walking Dead content and
breakdowns of all the episodes in past
couple seasons guys thanks for watching
see you next week
bye bye